[Musique]
qui n'a jamais rêvé dans ces moments-là
d'éradiquer la totalité des moustiques
sur terre derrière cette innocente
bataille nocturne entre un primate de 70
kg est un insecte de 3 mg se joue en
réalité une guerre millénaire cette nous
oppose au pire ennemi de l'humanité
encore aujourd'hui et chaque année le
moustique provoque des millions de décès
et lions les tigres et les requins
cumulés c'est seulement 1500 morts le
moustique ses limites le sommet de la
chaîne alimentaire non seulement ils
nous sucent le sang
mais c'est aussi l'animal le plus
meurtrier de tous la cause les parasites
et arbovirus que transmettent et
moustique provoquant entre autres
paludisme fièvre jaune dengue
chikungunya et c'est pourquoi n'éradique
on ne pas alors tous les moustiques sur
terre main est bien capable de détruire
involontairement les abeilles alors
pourquoi ne pas mettre toute cette
énergie au service d'une cause plus
nobles comme démonter cette foutue
bestiole est ce vraiment possible
et surtout est-ce vraiment souhaitable
on va essayer de répondre à toutes ces
questions
comment pouvons nous tuer tous les
moustiques sur terre pour se lancer dans
cette tête un peu folle commençons par
repérer la cible combien existe-t-il de
moustiques dans le monde
la réponse n'est pas si évidente déjà
simplement en alaska on dénombre 7
millions de moustiques sur toute la
terre des scientifiques se sont penchés
sur la question et on reste encore sans
réponse
par contre sur edit on retrouve quelques
internautes avec une belle estimations
70 quadrillions répartis en trois mille
cinq cents espèces différentes
il faudrait une quantité incroyable
d'insecticide pour éradiquer tout ça sur
les sites d'éradication de moustiques
on préconise environ 13 5 litres
d'insecticides sur 93 mètres carrés la
surface des terres émergées et en 249
millions de kilomètres carrés on peut
dire qu'il nous faut un peu moins de 21
millions de litres d'insecticides vous
imaginez le drame écologique avec toutes
les espèces touchées par ces produits
l'autre petite idée pour éradiquer les
moustiques serait de lancer un de ces
prédateurs naturels aux trousses
regardons les candidats oiseaux
insectivores libe
louvre nouilles n'ont pas assez nombreux
il nous faut un prédateur pouvoir
rivaliser en nombre pourquoi pas les
chauves souris elles elles sont capables
de manger 600 moustiques en une heure
donc si on a assez de chauves-souris
notre mission serait déjà terminée mais
connaissez-vous peut-être déjà la
réponse
les chauves-souris communique aussi des
maladies comme on a pu le voir
dernièrement avec les coronavirus mais
surtout comment pourrions-nous vivre
avec des milliards de chauves souris
dans le ciel à la place de moustiques
une troisième et dernière solution ce
serait ddt génétiquement les moustiques
la méthode consiste à relâcher dans la
nature des mâles génétiquement modifiés
dont la mission est de se reproduire
avec les femelles sauvages
vous allez me dire mais c'est pas
logique plus de moustiques égale plus de
naissances non c'est vrai mais les
larves nés de ces papas moustiques ogm
sont programmés pour mourir ça marche
car ça biaise la compétition sexuelle et
se mêlent ainsi mise enceinte ne sont
plus disponibles pour les moustiques
mâles normaux et ai vu qu'une femelle
pond en moyenne une centaine d'offres
c'est juste sans moustiques en moins on
fait ça avec des millions de moustiques
pendant quelques années et vous
détruisez totalement l'espèce c'est ce
qu'on fait actuellement dans le monde
pour exterminer aedes egypti le
moustique responsable de la dengue
comment serait le monde sans les
moustiques voilà le président de l'om s
l'a annoncé à la télé les moustiques ont
totalement été éradiquée de la surface
de la terre
ça va permettre à des millions de
personnes de ne pas tomber malade et
mourir fini les piqûres nocturne fini ce
petit bruit dans l'oreille quand tu dors
la liberté mais quel sera le prix à
payer pour ça eh bien il sera bien moins
lourd qu'on ne le pense
non mais attends et la chaîne
alimentaire dans tout ça comment les
oiseaux et les chauves souris vont faire
pour se nourrir là aujourd'hui ça ne
représente que 1% de leur alimentation
ce n'est pas assez nutritifs pour eux
ouais mais la pollinisation des plantes
par les moustiques mâles qui
transportait du pollen comme les
abeilles
encore une fois il ne politisent pas
assez ou plutôt police bien les
mauvaises plantes dans un article de
nature en 2010 claudio lazare il
reconnaît que les moustiques polynice
effectivement des plantes non
consommable donc pourquoi ne pas les
éradiquer s'il n'y a apparemment aucune
conséquence négative
plusieurs raisons à ça déjà bas sur les
3500 espèces il n'y en a que 200 qui
s'attaque à l'homme et 6 qui propagent
des maladies graves
le reste soit végétarienne soit ne sont
pas lectrice de maladie est ce que ça
vaut le coup de faire à génocide pour
quelques mauvaises élèves
peut-être pas la deuxième raison c'est
qu'ils ont des effets bénéfiques sur
quelques écosystème spécifique la forêt
amazonienne les pleins d'articles les
moustiques pollinisent où les oiseaux
migrateurs qui se servent de nos amis
comme des snacks pour garder la force ce
n'est que des exemples ce qu'on craint
alors c'est un effet papillon
imaginons avec des chiffres fantaisistes
que les moustiques sont nécessaires 0,1
pour cent des animaux 6 et 0,1 pour cent
disparaissent bon c'est dommage mais ce
n'est pas la fin du monde
maintenant c'est 0,1 pour cent animaux
servent de nourriture pour 1 % d'autres
animaux et ce même 1% servent à nourrir
10 autres pour cent les conséquences en
chaîne sont imprévisibles et la
disparition des moustiques pour est
involontairement condamné la planète
entière les pires signer pour se
protéger des moustiques
il existe de nombreuses idées reçues sur
ce qui fait fuir ou attire les
moustiques et on va commencer par les
ultrasons il y à des applications
téléchargées des millions de fois des
vidéos youtube avec des vues
astronomiques et des bracelets ultrasons
vendu une fortune un youtube heures a
donc testé pour vous et ça ne marche
absolument pas la science elle-même a
invalidé l'efficacité de cette méthode
deuxième idée reçue les lumières quelque
chose qui est une idée reçue par contre
c'est de croire que les lumières jaunes
les led et les écrans attire les
moustiques
c'est faux des études ont été menées en
1996 et 97 aux etats unis moins de 1%
des insectes attirés et et des
moustiques
si vous voulez vraiment vous protéger il
existe quelques remèdes tester et
reconnu le premier ce sont les plantes
oui s'asperger de citronnelle ou
d'eucalyptus itri odorat marche le
citronnée lol et le géraniol contenues
dans ces plantes mettre les moustiques
dans un état de stress intense
le système nerveux du moustique se place
en hyper activité comme si un danger
foncé sur eux ce sont les plans quelques
connu mais il y en ad'autres d'autres
ont des effets bien violent sur le
cerveau du moustique mais bon j'imagine
que vous vous souciez peu de l'état
mental de celui ci qu'il dégage ça
suffit
la molécule que tous les moustiques
craignent c'est le dit d'été un produit
utilisé pour la première fois durant la
guerre du vietnam par les soldats
américains
il devait bien se protéger eux aussi la
concentration du produit a été ensuite
limité à 50% à cause de sa toxicité
on a fait des tests avec des mains
aspergé c'est assez impressionnant le
seul problème du dit
c'est qu'à force dans aspergé partout on
soupçonne les moustiques de commencer à
développer une tolérance
d'ailleurs une des questions que vous
posez tous c'est pourquoi certaines
personnes attire les moustiques et
d'autres non pourquoi mon pote à 0
piqûres et vous vous faites totalement
défoncé la chaleur et les odeurs qui se
dégagent de votre peau sont des signaux
qui vous localise ils sont en premier
lieu attiré par le dioxyde de carbone
co2 que vous dégagez quand vous respirez
sont même capables de les détecter à
près de 30 mètres
les odeurs de l'acide lactique urique
l'alcool ou encore l'ammoniac sondés
second facteur le moustique adore ça du
coup désolé pour les personnes sportives
qui transpire mais vous avez plus de
chance de vous faire piquer que d'autres
notre alimentation et physiologie ont un
impact sur ces facteurs peuvent vous
rendre plus ou moins attirante pour le
moment il ya deux idées retenues par les
scientifiques
d'abord que ces personnes puissent
sécréter des composés chimiques les
rendent en repoussant aux yeux des
moustiques l'octane alnot nadal tu es
canal et la surca tonnes tout un
cocktail dont l'origine est votre
génétique environnement et alimentation
la deuxième idée c'est que la personne
continue de se faire piquer mais à moins
de sensibilité et de démangeaisons
l'organisme s'est habitué en effet son
corps va libérer - d'anticorps y ge et
ti gg ce responsable de cette petite
bosse rouge et de ses démangeaisons
par contre il ne faut pas compter
exclusivement là dessus le corps humain
réagit différemment selon les personnes
on dénombre plus 30% de la population
tolérante à leur boutique locaux on a
fait une étude où un homme a accepté de
se faire piquer des dizaines de milliers
de fois sur 26 semaines pour que le
corse est de réagir pour à jeu le gars
j'espère que ces conseils vous seront
utiles et que vous puissiez aborder la
question des moustiques de façon plus
apaisée à partir d'aujourd'hui c'est
aussi le rôle de notre chaîne de vous
faire imaginer des mondes meilleurs et
d'emc et les idées reçues donc n'hésitez
pas à liker à vous abonner
si vous souhaitez plus de vidéos du
genre un très grand merci à bois pour le
montage de la vidéo
retrouvez nous sur twitter c'était ma
tarn merci de nous avoir suivis ciao
[Musique]